In this sprouts teaching technique, we introduce
cold call; a simple question method teachers can
use to increase attention, boost energy and
get a better understanding of their students.
Teachers often raise a question and pick the
first hand that goes up, likely that's a good
and motivated student sitting in the first row
already knowing the answer. The student who is
less eager and less likely to know the answer
is dozing off in the back and that's a problem.
With cold calls the teacher randomly
names a student to give the answer
J name some ideal conditions for growing rice.
The benefit for the students is that everybody
gets a shot and since no student would know who
is next they all have to pay attention
this gives shy students more voice,
increases the energy level and creates a feeling
of fellowship as all students are equally treated.
The teachers also benefit. First, it's more fun
because everybody feels more engaged. Second,
it's fast as he or she doesn't need
to wait for hands to go up. Third,
the teacher gets a better understanding of who
already mastered a concept or who needs more help.
When you introduce cold calls we recommend
using simple questions to get students on
board. Once they are prepared the level can
raise. In a more advanced form, teachers can
use cold calls to moderate a discussion.
If Jay got the answer only half right,
the teacher could go on and say Sonia give Jay
a hint about the weather rice seeds seemed to
like. Then the teacher turns back to J to give
him another shot to get it completely right.
Please use the comment section below to let
us know what you think. If you are a student,
tell us if your teacher uses
cold calls. If you are a teacher,
share with us how you apply it in class and
if it works for you. We're releasing updates
regularly so don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel. Thank you for watching!